an absolute huge fan of this man uh he
was on our rich eisen show podcast
episode from the end
the nfl draft many years ago and now
he's in the last og season four
currently airing tuesdays at 10 pm
eastern on tbs i love his work
from 30 rock saturday night live and so
much more the great tracy morgan here on
the rich eisen show how are you tracy
that was awesome thanks rich i'm fine
how are you how was that intro i thought
i think it's worthy of a man of your
stature i really do i thought it was
awesome thank you i greatly appreciate
that
uh so uh let's let's jump right into it
uh how how into the uh knicks these days
are you tracy i went to the new york
times
i'm the biggest fit fan is besides spike
me and spike you know the knicks is
doing well they went way hell ahead of
schedule they're doing great they're
playing great ball and they're balling
um we just lose two in a row but that's
okay you're not gonna win every game
right uh the difference is impeccable
when they turn it up the defense is
incredible i'm glad they brought into
scissors ideas i'm glad they brought
into his plan and they look like they
like playing together again we got nick
pratt is back in the garden uh it is it
it feels like just there's no noise like
the garden when it's rocking it really
when the garden is on fire do you know
what john lennon called new york city he
called it rome man
we're in the city of the universe
who's your favorite who's your name
who's your favorite nick of all time
i don't have a favorite but i love pat
man
i'm a houston pat
bernard
come on you can't say one you got that
one for me you can't say one mine is
bernard king
he's my favorite come on bernard is a
friend of mine i could call bernard on
the phone right now
[Laughter]
bernard is the king baby
you well he yeah so you have bernard
king tracy morgan you have bernard king
on your on your speed dial you could
just you could just call him up you
could do this literally like literally
no lie literally we talk with friends
we're very good friends
he's from fort greene projects in
brooklyn on a few conquest projects
right up the block
he was my favorite i remember seeing him
when he got hurt after he hurt his knee
and i ran it literally as i was going
into an elevator at madison square
garden in high school he was in it and
he was wearing this like gorgeous coat
like this beautiful like dress coat just
standing there and i couldn't speak
i honestly i could not speak i was so in
awe of his presence tracy morgan king
and now julius randall wears his number
kind of throws me off seeing that to be
honest with you oh man
just fair homage i know
bernard king baby okay and the yankees
are you into them too
tracy what i worked at gave four for
like 10 years so scalping tickets
selling sylvanas selling pretzels come
on man i live right off the block from
yankee stadium i'm the old stadium
though that's where i grew up at the old
stadium i grew up at the new one yeah
went that day when they actually handed
out weapons to fans the first ten
thousand fences
i overcharged for those weapons too
i had to give back more michaels i had
to give him back twenty dollars you know
overcharge them for like two three
shirts and four bats now hold on a
second because that you know we we do
play uh a game called celebrity true or
false with our with our with our guests
and you that might as well just let's
based on based on some things that we
read we might as well hit that can you
hit that right here let's let's just go
for it with tracy morgan we'll play
celebrity true or false with our uh with
our we we've got our whole um production
value to it go for it hit it please
celebrity true or false you can't handle
the truth there you go we got jack as
our production value okay that that was
my first item for you is it true that
you met lorne michaels as a vendor at
yankee stadium the snl founder is that
true four gate four
and i was i was a kid and um
he was they my friends told me that's
lauren michaels i saw michaels he came
out of the player's gate and um i
overcharged him for like three bats and
some shirts some yankee shirts and then
that when i became a cast member i gave
him back like 14.
in some sense and he said what's this
for i said cause i overcharged you for
some items
he started laughing he started dying
this is when you said game four like
what the 96 world series is that what
that was tracy uh what do you think
it was it was a it was a devil jesus no
no no manically i think manning lee was
playing okay so that was probably like
95 or something like that okay so yeah
so you're right so what were you doing
out there you were selling stuff so we
were dropping tickets i scout tickets i
sold souvenirs and unsold cocaine
[Laughter]
and that's when it was 21
i'm getting 45 regardless of how it go
down for me
so this is true sorry because i live
right up the hill so i had tickets i had
cocaine that ass over there
[Laughter]
you got it all that's what you're saying
back in the day 20 twenty one dollars a
gram
and so you sold hats and bats and stuff
like that and that's how you met uh
that's amazing don't forget the goat
you got something in there
tracy really was hustle man from martin
back in the day
he really was hustle man
i was i was i worked silver there and i
was 21 town on the side
tracy morgan right here on the rich
eisen show amidst the greatest celebrity
true or false of all time uh um here's
one too uh true or false you beat out
stephen colbert in the final round of
your saturday night live audition is
that true them and marc maron
you took care of you took them all down
so
i became a star
so how did you get the how did you get
the audition to begin with how did that
happen
well first i was with barry catch barry
had me dave chappelle and jim brewer jim
jimbo got it and then i auditioned they
didn't want to give me an audition at
first and then they very catching them
talk them into let's just seeing me and
i got on stage with my propeller hat at
the comic strip and i went all out and
so what went all out like i was revenge
in my brother's death
so what was your what was your number
one act what do you think god got you
the audition what was the number one bit
talked about doodle
to talked about what
i'm talking about
baby
that's not chocolate that's doo-doo baby
that was your bit that was your that was
one of your i talked about michael
jackson doodling
what was it like for michael jackson can
i curse go for it
what was it like for michael jackson to
take
[Laughter]
and how did that go how did that go how
did that go
bubbles bring me some toilet paper
simone and that got you the auditions
that got you the audition and then what
what what what what said michael jackson
the night before he took us he had some
pork and beans and hot dogs
what landed the what landed the snl gig
then do you remember anything from the
audition that that you think see i did
the same thing when i went up i did all
of that for laura michaels at the comic
strip and then i got the lads and i did
some i did a lot of stuff and then they
gave him a job they gave me the gig okay
and from there i started saying give me
a soda
now the last one i have for you is it
true or false your favorite snl
character is astronaut jones that you
did is that true or false no i love all
the characters that i played
i love all the characters but the one
that was closest to me was
was um
woodrow
okay why is that
that was starting to show my serious
side okay i got the girl off the girl
you know girl boy gets girl boy loses
girl
boy gets girl back but i never got the
girl back
little tv set
going off inside my ear
face man floating by
firecracker beer
chase the demons lightly
oops upside my mind
up and down the sidewalk
take
[Music]
was there ever one um idea that you came
up with or
or anything else that you were involved
with where they said we can't do that
on snl
no no no um
um the idea i came up with was uh
um
brian fellow
yeah
i came up and now we did it but he
changed the name from brian fellow to
brian fellowes
okay
hi i'm brian fellow we did that
we're looking at me bird
that bird is looking at me
so rich i'll just say this as you know
uh tracy you might not remember this
years ago you got punked i'm friends
with ashton kutcher so i used to always
see you back in the day and brian
fellowes to this day ashton and i will
still call each other up and go i'm
brian fellows that sounds crazy
[Laughter]
yeah i remember that park too because
eddie murphy said that was one of his
favorite ones because i went street i
became street i went back to brooklyn on
it
what happened
it was
something about we towed tracy's car he
was at a club
on um no no no i was at work i would
work on the street and then we were at
somewhere on studio city on ventura and
then what happened
so what happened tracy you come take my
car for me man i wasn't having it
i was a jaguar
did you turn brook you turned brooklyn
huh you went back to your roots brooklyn
i went straight brooklyn on here then do
or die take the girl kill the god
oh yeah we told him we were going to tow
his car to like barstow or something oh
something ridiculous like that and tracy
was not having it it was it was a great
it was a great punk too it was great
well tracy this is amazing that was one
of the best uh certain library true or
falses we've ever had um
how are you enjoying doing the last og
let's talk about that
yeah i love that show it's very dear
dear to me
because i get to relive a lot of things
in my life
and uh you know it's surreal and a lot
of things are coming to me now in my
older age and i just put in a show a lot
of situations and it is
some black actors on it but it's really
a show about the struggle and the
struggle is real the struggles everybody
knows about the struggle everybody on
the planet knows about the struggle i
don't care if you jeff face those and
you own amazon everybody need a reason
to get out of bed in the morning that's
the hardest part of the day is getting
out of bed
[Music]
so you gotta know what's your reason my
reason is my kids
yeah same with me i agree with you
the one my best coach saw on the show is
my daughter she's eight years old she's
a coach she's my co-star on the show
so that's why this show means a lot to
me my daughter's in it and how are you
feeling these days you feel good i feel
great i feel great you know i don't know
about tomorrow but i know about today i
feel great today i'm i'm i'm doing an
interview with you right now i love it
you don't get no better than that no i
and i
man i just am so
thrilled to see you and whenever i hear
you and see you you give so much joy to
so many people tracy so the fact that
you're you know you're doing well and
then you know the last og gives you such
pleasure to do it's it's great you
deserve that man you really do bless you
very much you really do and that's uh
that's tuesday's 10 eastern time on tbs
currently in season four everyone should
check it out it's tracy doing doing
doing his thing thanks for the time
tracy morgan you're the best man and
thank you very much right back at you at
tracy morgan on both twitter and
instagram the last og airs tuesdays at
10 eastern on tbs
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here